[Music]
if it were not for Johanna vano Bunger
the world would never have known the
starry night or even heard of Vincent
Veno or rather Vincent Van ho though I'm
definitely butchering the Dutch
pronunciation while Vincent was alive
hardly anyone knew his work Beyond a
small circle of artists tired of the
hustle and bustle of Paris where he
tried to make a name for himself he left
for the south of France he dreamt to
building his own artist community at his
home in Al and CO's fellow painter Paul
Goan to live with it but Goan didn't
want to be an a calling it the dirtiest
hole in the South Vincent's dreams were
dashed 2 days before Christmas in 1888
they had a huge fight and in a fit of
rage Vincent turned on himself and cut
off his left ear we don't know the exact
nature of Vincent's Illness but doctors
and historians today believe he may have
suffered from bipolar disorder when he
voluntarily checked himself into a
psychiatric hospital in s the provin
paintings seemed to calm him but his
deep anguish remained 2 months after
leaving the hospital he shot himself in
the chest his brother Tao rushed to be
by his side where he died on July 29
1890 Vincent Van go was just 37 years
old as ta put it in a letter to their
mother life weighs so heavily on him
Vincent death also weighed heavily on
his brother teo's already weakened
Health deteriorated H 6 months after
Vincent took his own life Teo died of
the effects of syphilis he was 33 years
old the medical file noted that the
cause of teo's decline was hereditary
chronic illness excessive strain and
grief tail left behind a son who was not
even one and a devastated wife when
Johanna or yo as she was commonly called
married Tao the Dutch woman was whisked
away to Paris the center of the art
world where Tao worked as an art dealer
tirelessly promoting his brother's
extensive collection of nearly 900
paintings teao spent his life trying to
raise awareness of his brother's work
but struggled V Go's post-impressionism
style characterized by loose brush work
even Bolder colors than impressionism
and great emotional depth was in Star
contrast to traditional art which
emphasized finely detailed brush work
precise lines and a polished finish
despite the lack of enthusiasm for
Vincent's art tail believed in his
brother's genius writing to Yo one day
he will be understood after teo's death
yo made it her mission for the world to
understand and appreciate Vincent Van
Go's art declaring it is the only thing
I can do in memory of my husband and for
Vincent this is the story of how she
made Vincent vano famous when Teo died
unexpectedly less than 2 years after
marrying Joe she left Paris and moved to
butchen Southeast of Amsterdam a village
home to writers artists and
intellectuals because teao didn't leave
a will half of Vincent's hundreds of
Works went to Yo and the other half to
his son Vincent named after his uncle
van go dedicated Almond Blossom to his
nephew y looked after the boy share for
the time being since he wasn't of age
she converted her large home into a
boarding house and stored many of
Vincent's paintings that didn't fit on
her walls in the Attic she then hatched
a plan to achieve recognition for
Vincent as described in the book of
Better Life by Hans Lon yo began
knocking on doors like a traveling
salesman she tapped into her late
husband teo's contacts in the art world
to approach art dealers Galleries and
critics seeking opportunities for sales
exhibitions in publicity for Vincent's
paintings she gave museums discounts on
Works they were interested in acquiring
or even donated them recognizing this
would increase public exposure it also
aligned with her belief that art should
be accessible to everyone not just
privileged reflecting her socialist
values she organized exhibitions in
Paris the hag antor Amsterdam Berlin and
later London and New York she managed
everything coordinating with shipping
companies for the careful transport of
Vincent's paintings handling payments
for florists and overseeing the
provision of coffee to name a few she
thanked her artist friends who helped
her out by generously gifting them van
goes this not only showed her
appreciation for their support but also
had the effect of exposing Vincent's
work to the broader art community
Vincent's reputation began to build 15
years after his death with a pivotal
Exhibition at Amsterdam stead leak
Museum in 1905 no known photos of the
exhibition exist so we used AI in a bit
of our own editing to imagine what it
looked like as 484 paintings and
drawings were displayed the largest van
go exhibit ever yo smartly asked a
number of people who own van go to lend
them for the exhibition as proof of his
popularity her son Vincent helped
arrange and hang the paintings while her
second husband Johan an artist stayed in
touch with potential buyers when the
public first saw van goard some were
shocked by the bold colors and dramatic
brush Strokes an art critic wrote daring
to exhibit such shoddy work is
scandalous he suggested the star night
looks like donuts whereas another critic
took the opposite view writing the work
will grip you and never let you go love
him or hate him they talked about him
which drove up the price of Vincent's
art gone were the days of sell ing a van
go painting like the interior of a
restaurant for only 180 Franks or the
equivalent of around
$35 based on the gold standard of the
time after the exhibition a Parisian
Gallery purchased the painting the
bedroom which depicts van Go's own
bedroom for 3,000 Dutch gilders or
around 1200 in US whereas 5 years before
yo turned down an offer for the same
painting of only 500 gilders or
$200 she believed it was better to sell
a few works for good prices than more
works works for low prices in order to
preserve the value of the art she also
always made sure not to flood the market
with Van go understanding that scarcity
could increase their value the surgeon
vanco's popularity was further fueled by
new generation of collectors who were
increasingly drawn to the expressive
qualities of Modern Art despite her
success yo faced another tragedy when
her second husband Yan died of pacy an
inflammation of the lining of the lungs
in 1912 at the age of 38 yo lamented
here I am alone again and the only thing
that sustains me and gives me the
courage to continue is the love for my
dear son and the duty to look after the
interests of Vincent's work she buried
herself deeper into her work including
publishing all of Vincent's letters so
that the public could get to know him as
a human being hoping it would Foster a
deeper appreciation for his art she
organized edited and arranged the 820
surviving letters sent by Vincent 658 of
which were to his best friend and most
loyal supporter Teo the letters were all
the more special because they contained
sketches to give teao an idea of what he
was working on teao treasured and
preserved his letters from Vincent when
they were published in 1914 first in
Dutch readers were struck by the
intensity of Vincent's writing success
is sometimes the outcome of a whole
string of failures find things beautiful
as much as you can most people find too
little beautiful the sight of the Stars
always makes me dream yo often wept as
she poured through the letters she
worked tirelessly to translate them into
English drawing on her earlier
experience working as an English teacher
and also her time spent living in New
York during World War I even as
Parkinson's disease caused her hands to
tremble she persisted in her translation
work eventually relying on others to
dictate letters she managed to translate
2third of the letters into English
English before she passed away
peacefully in her sleep on September 2nd
1925 as she neared the end of her life
she could see the fruits of her lifelong
dedication Vincent's art once confined
to an attic now graced to museums in
Europe and the United States among them
were masterpieces she had promised to
hold on to Forever yet made the
difficult decision to let them go when
she sold one of the Beloved sunflower
paintings to the National Gallery in
London she explained to the museum
director it is a sacrifice for the sake
of Vincent's Glory reflecting on the
dramatic change in the perception of En
Go's art yo confided to an art critic it
is so good after so many years of public
indifference even hostility towards
Vincent in his work to feel towards the
end of my life that the battle is
won following Yo's death her son Vincent
took over the van go collection and was
dedicated to ensuring it would stay
accessible for future Generations he
helped establish the Vincent Van go
Foundation leading to the creation of
the van go Museum in Amsterdam Vincent
Van go once wrote It's a rather sad
Prospect to have to say to myself that
the painting I do will perhaps never
have any value how wrong he was if only
he could see the admiration the world
has for him today in an episode of the
British Science Fiction show Doctor Who
the time traveler doctor brings ven go
to the Future where he's taking in an
exhibit of his own work to me vanov is
the finest painter of the
all certainly the most popular great
painter of all
time the value of his legacy is not
measured in mere emotional impact but
also in astounding prices in 2022
Orchard with cypresses was purchased at
christe's auction house for
117.1 million the most expensive vano
painting ever sold underscoring the
profound influence he continues to have
on the art World an influence that yo
van go Bunger spent 35 years cultivating
as one headline aptly put it without yo
there would have been no van go did you
know that the Starry Night mirrors a
scientific concept not fully grasped
until years after its creation that
would be turbulent flow van Go's ability
to visually represent this phenomenon
possibly intuitively is a testament to
his deep observation of the natural
world if you'd like to foster a deep
understanding of the World by improving
your skills in math science computer
science and data science I highly
recommend brilliant.org a website and
app to help you learn interactively and
it's free for you to try out just as van
go intuitively touched upon scientific
principles in his art brilliant offers
courses designed to enhance your
scientific thinking through engaging
Hands-On puzzles I like to spend 10
minutes a day on Brilliance logic
puzzles to improve my analytical
thinking Brilliance courses are designed
to let you start at your own pace and
gradually build up to more advanced
topics if you find yourself stuck on a
problem you can view the explanation to
understand the right approach you can
try out brilliant for free for 30 days
by visiting my custom link in the
description brilliant.org
newws plus if you're one of the first
200 people to sign up through my link
you'll receive 20% off your premium
subscription giving you full access to a
world of knowledge thanks for watching
for news think I'm Cindy Palm